wir sind das Land das nach den USA die
Ukraine am meisten unterstützt wir
machen das vor allem jetzt mit Panzern
mit Artillerie wir haben das gemacht mit
sehr viel Luftverteidigung gerade heute
hat der ukrainische Präsident eine
Message abgesendet überall danke Olaf
gemeint ist natürlich Danke Deutschland
für die aktuellen Lieferung im Bereich
von Patricks zur Luftverteidigung und so
wie in der Vergangenheit werden wir jede
einzelne Entscheidung immer sehr
sorgfältig überprüfen was geht was Sinn
macht was unser Beitrag sein kann und
meinen Eindruck ist dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das in der ganz großen
Mehrheit sehr sehr richtig finden das
nicht jedes Mal wenn einer irgendwo in
einer
irgendwo in einem Gesprächen sagt das
noch das noch dann immer gleich gesagt
und ja sondern dass wir uns schwer
machen wir werden es uns weiter schwer
machen
[Musik]